I walk into the studio every morning I
give the message of let's think of what
we can do instead of what people tell us
we can't do you do yes I watch how you
handled Nancy Grace you were very
graceful yeah you really really you were
classy unlace like you saw with you she
was so nice to me right before the
camera went on like I was like oh this
is gonna be awesome
right cuz she was so nice I took a
picture I had to die but cut her
everything but I know before the show
before the show what do you think of her
after the show I wanted to kill her
choke her out you know my wife said to
me would she shake her head like no cuz
I was so pissed before into the
interview did you realize oh wow pretty
quick oh Jesus
she just started talking she started
talking about the steroid scandal that
was 25 years ago
right DDP was on the show or she was
talking about the Ultimate Warrior's
death that's what we confronted her on
the show who did I didn't know any of
this stuff Sam knew all of it and she
brought up like she's like listing the
wrestlers that have died and she puts
like Owen Hart who died you know in the
ring and and like you know all the guys
who died of gunshot wounds and just
stuff that had nothing to do lumping it
all in with that exactly and think about
his kids and wife at that time right
like I wonder like because they are the
nicest people and for a warrior to come
back you know and I was just so happy
that everything was fixed beforehand
that happened so he could be put in the
spot that he deserved to be in right and
you know I thought we were gonna talk
about you know the time like imagine is
I'm it's WrestleMania six I'm the driver
for the hockey talk man in a pink
Cadillac
like the car my pink Cadillac
convertible got the gig not me so that's
how you got the gig as the driver
because you had a pink car exam pick a
who's Luke the bushwhackers good buddy
man he came out my club but he saw the
convertible he's like dude I think I get
you at mania I'm like seriously I just
want to go right you know and I'm
already Diamond Dallas Page but for this
damn would be diamond dollz show what
kind of club was it um the co bio is a
dance club oh it strip club no no I like
dancing
are you if I were growing up in the
strip club business I would have been so
[ __ ] at the same time uh-huh but I met
that at that mania Hogan and warrior are
the main event right so now let's go
eight ten years later dude eight years
later eight years later and now I'm the
main event with Goldberg and I'm sharing
it with warrior and Hogan why with WCW
so when warrior comes in like he calls
for you know he has someone get me and
Goldberg and we go to see him and he was
so cool you're so gracious he goes I
want you guys to know you're the reason
why I'm doing this I see you guys having
so much fun
I wanted to be part of the fun again wow
that was that's what I wanted to say
yeah and warriors the guy who at the
time was bitter about the business so
the fact that he saw that it was fun
again yes he's like I want to go back
and have a good time like he wanted he
liked it and he yo cuz he oh he loved it
growing up with the whole deal but you
know that that we were a part of helping
him want to do that like that's what I
wanted to talk about is that way they
brought you in saying that you were
gonna talk about how they they always
you assume because of what happens
they're gonna have some memories of the
word then I didn't really think soon as
she started I thought oh my god dude
you're on TV with Nancy Grace now like
be killer yeah she can be a sweetheart
you've seen her be that too right I
thought that was one of these days
especially when she was a fan well they
say she's a pig and she went on like the
view and all the shows after she did our
show and acted like this sweet lady was
the victim of everything like she was
just bombarded she walked in here and
Jim and I just completely just you talk
about it oh yes you so fine yes what a
baby she was the one went on baby she
went on the view and she called us
beavis and butthead Oh
the best all bullies no matter what they
can't take being bullied right and you
weren't even bullying you were just
asking for some facts like let me call
you on your [ __ ] right you're both like
I was like wow these guys are really
doing this nicely but you know you know
she knew right away oh my god they're
doing to me what I do to people for a
real griller of interviews she [ __ ]
collapse fast like she was look like she
was willing to fight like she's
definitely ferocious but then she just
ends the interview and leaves right not
me doing yeah you're on TV so you can't
exactly when you're on her show you
can't that's that's what I'm thinking
right I'm I'm thinking if I get up and
walk away I'm going to embarrass the
business right because it makes it look
like it you are on drugs and won't tell
anybody about it right you can't
I'm just breathe he did say and I
remember talking about this you know I
said it then I've said it numerous times
WWE has the the highest standard of
policy like for drugs and everything
like cuz if so many guys have going down
you know over the years they're they
have the strictest policy way stricter
than the NFL right or the MLB like way
stricter you had some you have some
painkiller in you somewhere
you better have like the exact reasons a
doctor everything and they're just the
guys today they don't do pills right my
day everybody did you know and you know
again today these guys are they're not
out partying all night long let's say to
no party but not like we did you know
they're playing video games or on
computers and you know it's just a
different generation you know yeah yeah
yeah I'm happy for them cuz there's a
whole lot of amazing athletes out there
so she ambushed you basically nice yeah
again I get but so dice before gym so
what do you what do you do after the
show like what do you do once the once
the segments over and she goes well
thank you Dallas for joining us I you
know I I don't remember what I said but
I know I said something in a way of like
go [ __ ] yourself but I didn't say that
right I said it very language language
this is my house
I just knowing the Internet
yes I knew the fallout what was about to
come right you remember I went did your
show oh yeah right after that you didn't
you dropped you drop the C bomb on her
what'd you say and he was like he was
like I don't even want to talk about
because I remember you're like saying
I'll talk to you about it but I'm not
talking to anybody else about it after
this you and I didn't see it coming
but Dallas likes to be and he goes Sam
I'll tell you Nancy she she was a
Content yeah I was so I was so mad
because again the fallout that came on
the Internet
and I was more worried and concerned
with the family forget me you know
forget it I didn't want them right to
feel that